they are more concerned impossible yes
they would be yeah and I hope this
teaches and preaches and mounted ever be
taken there are people let us unified
shut this now what brought you what
brought me here today is that I live in
Detroit and my community is being
devastated by foreclosures you know
who's the federal government bailout
with the bank's the rich people they're
not they're not helping bailout the
people i know we're here to demand a
national moratorium on foreclosures and
evictions and utility cut-offs because
people are losing their jobs because
it'll be losing our their homes and
enough is enough basically i think that
people are being made to feel guilty
then they're not paying off you know
their own debts and so far that they got
themselves into this and they should get
themselves out of it but apparently the
government doesn't feel that way when it
comes to bear stearns or any of the
banks that are on Wall Street that they
are there for them you know overnight
whenever they need money what we have
here but just because we need a
moratorium on these foreclosures people
are using their houses also the fact
that we have 45,000 people in Detroit
there have done don't have no lights gas
and water
it's not just this crisis administration
it goes to the core of the values of our
society that I think needs to be changed
so you would you would see you see sort
of a Bolshevik there weren't problem
specifically but i think that there's
also problems with capitalism I don't
think capitalism the solution to the
problems of people world and people did
a lot better by any objective standard
the life expectancy the education rate
on their health care than they did you
know pre rebels unless your posts taller
then you're in life expectancy was
fairly low right I mean listen to their
were there was a war on the Russian
Revolution it wasn't as it they were out
to come to have some like social
experiment on their own on opposed by
the rest of the world there were nothing
there were problems with it I milliner
that's not a solace and I'm a socialist
but I'm a Marxist you know a scientific
Marcus myself we can we think in a
system with the socialism where the
means of production are owned by the
people where the profits are owned and
shared the wealth is shared concrete the
workers those who create well I'm a
socialist so it does appeal to me and
I've been in coover several times and I
see you know there are not luxuries but
people have food people have education
free universal healthcare everyone has a
house everyone has a job everyone has
education you know it's free I think
education should be free myself and that
all those student loans should be
Hansel yeah so when I visited Cuban I
talked to a lot of youth in the streets
you know people very free to speak out
about what they thought you know you
know most people supported what was
going on because the material conditions
our lives are very very good and
socialism it can be rationally planned
it's not it's not playing it's not like
you know you know decided by these
different bankers and different
corporations fighting amongst themselves
for the profits in the leap it's
actually decided by the people you know
by the government not by the
corporations in the capitalists so yes I
do believe in and more socialized
medicine and socialize a structure which
people are more important than the
profits of corporations and banks this
is music and culture is simply
satellites from Miami targeting Cuban
youth to like undermine the revolution
to cause antisocial behavior
being brought up for when the ambrosia
ball one who has been you're still
around from death row each and every
last one across from their corporate
these beware because it a raft of people
taking my first down what does the lease
occupation of our communities and police
brutality against brown and black people
what is that constitute I don't believe
in civil rights civil rights is more a
dog or cat a mouse it's not for you what
a simple me what you have to be simply
in order to lil haiti the prices of food
has gone up sixty percent and people are
starving to death and eating dirt mixed
with oil the wrong child the banks
already know that the Federal Reserve
has already been privatized the people
of Iraq don't have any patience anymore
they will fight you with rocks they will
fight you with sticks but whatever they
have is gonna spawn zone they come and
they drop bombs on our home they talk
farms and our communities they drop
bombs and Baghdad they drop bombs in
Haiti they jump farms in Afghanistan
they drop bombs in colombia they drop
bombs and spill blood all around the
world you gonna make me watch TV what I
want to watch it I gotta have a
convertible you're gonna tell me the
TV's gonna going
isn't that summer form of communism I'm
eleni that's not a solace and I'm a
socialist when I'm a Marxist you know a
scientific Marcus myself I'm a socialist
funny man
good
Oh